ていた
[音楽]
ああ
動画撮らないとね
[音楽]
ん
こんにちははじめ社長です今日人間ドッグに行ってきました去年人間ドックに行って
それから毎年ちょっとちゃんと受けようかなということで今年も人間ドック行ってき
ました
[音楽]
ん
うんいいよね間江船団よりもっと細かいんですよ人間ドック
身長とかたりするとかなんか視力とかじゃなくてもっとそのチっとか新レンズとかね
バリウム飲んでなんかぐるぐるぐるってされたりほんといろんなことが人間ドックが
わかるんでまぁちょっととんでもなく不規則でめちゃくちゃな生活してるんで
もう早期発見が何よりもいいんでちょっとちゃんと人間ドック
ko かなということで今年も行ってきたんですけども去年受けた時と大きく違うこと
が一つございましてそれは何かと言いますとお肉を食べていないそう
もう4月なんでお肉禁止してから約3ヶ月が経ちました
おにぐげーします動画のコメントの皆さん見ましたでしょうか
何人もの人が何人もの人がお前やめとけ危険だ
まずで危ないと思いますやめて
くださいたくさんの人からあぶなやめないと言われて
tony
強かったで死ぬ死ぬとか言われたら暴動は死ぬんじゃねぇかなとか思ってちょっと
怖かったんですけどそれも含めてなんか健康診断でその管理栄養士の方と書いたんで
本当にあの母校に禁止するんですけど大丈夫でしょうか
みたいな感じでちょっと聞いてみたりしたのでちょっと色々まとめて公開発表していき
たいとおもいます
[音楽]
ズバリん
結果から言いますと
[音楽]
めっちゃ目なりました yeah
いやまずねすごいですよあの原価から言いますと超健康になりましたこれも数値を見れ
ば一目瞭然でちょっといろいろ発表していきますよ
身長が変わらず186センチ体重が去年が65.6 k
私が118キロ
ちょっと増えましたねちなみに僕の標準体重は705.9kg です
まだまだ大丈夫ですねで肥満度が前回が-13%今年がマイナス10.4%
まだまだ痩せてます
ということです安心した体脂肪率14%から23%が基準出すんですけど僕は
13.2%でした体重だけど2.4キロぐらい去年から比べて太った何位でございます
平均より全然痩せ方だったんでむしろ太って何か良いよみたいな感じでした
ある健康診断して10年しぼみたらフっ子
お湯悪くてそれが原因をたどると多分ラーメンの食い過ぎだろうなっていうことで去年
ラーメン1年禁止したんですけどもうこちらですね前回から見ていきましょう去年が総
コレステロール
基準値が140から219で227
これ赤字になってるのがちょっと危ないでっていうやつでございます中性脂肪
よく聞きますよ
抽選死亡40たら149だったらまあ創面シーンですけども
去年なんと180 air
いやよくないんですよ本当にこれ見で僕まずでちょっとお医者さんに中戦車もたらせ
切り危ないですって言われてこちらが今年の結果です
どうぞ
あっ浜3-2世死亡70年
やばくないですか去年180度ってのがこの1077まで落としました
してご覧下さい去年赤字が3つあった奴が今赤字がありません
うぇいすべて
異常なしでございます学科
まずでよかっありがとうございますもうなんかもう戦場に本当に来禁止してるの
ちょっと怖くて書いたんですよお肉食べなくて心配ですって書いて
で色々聞いたんですけどやっぱ全然あり安いですよ肉禁止去年に比べてはるかに体が
良くなっている素晴らしい
とお褒めのお言葉をいただきましたありがとうございます唖然猫といえばラーメンとか
食ってるんですよ全然雨で送ってるんですけどもそれ以外のをに軽視することによって
なんか揚げ物とか脂っぽいのが全く苦はなくなっておそらくそういうところで中性脂肪
が結構
もう半分以下 nick at 落ちたのではないかなということでございますお肉
禁止は本当に阿部ないですやめた方
がいいですと言っていた皆様
neore
一つ言われたのはやっぱお肉禁止することによってお肉食べないと取り入れられない
栄養素があるからそこだけ気をつけてくださいということを言われました
てないでちゃんと意識的にタンパク質とか卵とか大豆とか
お肉のちゃんとか悪いなるものがあるのでそこをちゃんと食べてれば全く問題ないと
いう感じでございましたこれでもうニック刑事しまってから蛇行したら
マジでダサいなと思ってたんでよかったお肉禁止がすべてもいいんじゃないと思うん
ですけど間違いなく去年と比べて体が健康になっておりますまだ3ヶ月しかしてません
からねそれでこんだけ変わるってことはこれをに鍵 s して良かったんじゃねぇ
てお前星が9カ月後にくるように塗りたいと思います登り9ヶ月間だぞ
ん
me 2
me
うんっ
はぁ
6分